breaking news this thursday night
disaster strikes a tiny village
a wildfire engulfs most of litton b.c
the destruction
how people escaped get go go and the
heartache
our robin gill is near the fire zone
also
the country's shameful past front and
center
on canada day
the reckoning the reflections and the
recognition of residential school
victims and survivors
plus one boy's journey to channel his
anger
into action that could have been me in
one of those graves
and monumental memorial the new
permanent tribute to diana
the people's princess
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
farah nasser we've got to leave town
the town is on fire trail
go the panicked escape from litten
british columbia the village that made
headlines this week for
record-shattering heat is now a scene of
devastation
after being ravaged by a fast-moving
wildfire
good evening and thank you for joining
us as we track this developing story in
bc's interior
tonight it's still not clear whether
everyone made it out of litton safely
families are trying desperately to track
down loved ones
caught in the chaos but power outages
and for cell service
are making it difficult according to the
mp for the area
at least two people have died and 90
percent of the village
is destroyed to give you a sense of what
that looks like this
was litton's main street before the fire
and this
is after the province says most of the
homes are gone
as well as the local ambulance station
and rcmp detachment
a number of evacuation centers have been
set up for the people
forced to flee one of them is east of
litton in the city of merit
and that's where we find our robin gill
tonight robin what are you hearing from
people
well mostly that they're concerned about
their loved ones they want to make sure
that they got out safely because it was
such a frenetic and chaotic exit from
litten
and these families are scattered at
evacuation centers right around the
province that have been set up
but more than anything there's that
staggering stress that they've lost
everything
an arena in merit bc is a lifeline for
the many who left litton with minutes to
spare
star drynock's father stayed behind to
help fight the fire
and she hasn't been able to find him
have you heard anything from your dad
no it's terrifying because i know he
wouldn't
he wouldn't leave norman drynock is a
retired firefighter and wanted to help
save what homes he could
he chose to stay and we found out that
he was the last one to stay on reserve
to to fight the fire and save as many
houses as he can and he didn't leave
last night
it was a terrifying escape on a highway
obscured by smoke
chaotic you barely see
driving through the smoke and
then it kept pushing us further toward
kamloops
it finally chases right up to here the
wildfire overwhelmed the village of
lytton home to about a thousand people
and tony sam has been told his house was
reduced to nothing
by the flames do you know what's
happened to your house
[Music]
witnesses say there were sparks from a
train coming through and wonder if that
caused this wildfire
that'll be part of the investigation
right now the focus of firefighters is
to stop the flames from spreading
they've come from all across the
province basically when we got here last
night it had started to sort of hold but
uh from what we understand what we saw
this morning in terms of what the
destruction we've seen
and the property loss it seems to have
spread really fast
the province is promising more help to
those who've lost everything
this has been a very difficult day and
the days ahead are going to continue to
challenge us
star drynock had just bought a home for
her family right now
she doesn't even want to think about
that i woke up this morning
i was like what did we do it's like i
know we're safe but
there's like a lost feeling roads to
linton remain blocked off and the smoke
shrouding the area
gives little hope residents can return
home anytime
soon as you can see it's still very
windy conditions are dry it's very hot
and this is
when fires thrive and there are so many
fires still burning
right across the province but the danger
isn't over yet
pharah robin gill in merit b.c thank you
robin
and on that note multiple bc communities
are under evacuation orders tonight
because of fast moving wildfires
that includes hundreds of people in
castlegar and
deca lake who've been ordered to leave
their homes immediately
about a hundred active wildfires are
burning across bc
75 of them started in the past two days
officials say the extreme heat
has made for explosive conditions
i cannot stress enough how extreme the
fire
risk is at this time in almost every
part
of british columbia and i urge british
columbians to listen carefully
to officials in your communities and
follow those directions as best you can
many parts of bc are still sweltering in
a record-breaking heat wave
there are warnings across much of the
province and they also stretch all the
way into northwestern
ontario daytime highs are expected to
reach the mid-40s in some regions
this level of heat and for such a long
period of time
is unprecedented and it's expected to
stick around
until at least the weekend
in alberta another first nation has
begun searching for unmarked graves at
several residential school sites the
province was home to more residential
schools than
anywhere in the country two were on the
siksika first nation just east of
calgary
and today on canada day members gathered
in that community to honor the children
who never came home heather urex west
reports
the saint joseph indian residential
school was torn down
25 years ago but its impact continues to
be felt across the siksika first nation
leon crane bear's parents and
grandparents attended residential
schools
he did two in 1968. he was just
six years old i repressed a lot of those
memories i do talk to my father about
the residential
his residential school experience some
of our
you know are happy moments for him but
there's a lot of sad moments that he
doesn't like to talk about
on the other side of the first nation
the former old son residential school
still stands teddy bears surround two
teepees that sit
in front of the school it was here that
members of the six sika first nation
hosted a public tribute
to the children who attended these
schools a somber canada day gathering
that attracted hundreds of visitors
including kawasa's first nation chief
cadmus delorme
one week after he announced 751 unmarked
graves
were discovered near the site of the
maryvale residential school in
saskatchewan
in regina prairie crowe had hoped to
gather 751 backpacks to display on the
steps of the provincial legislature
in the end collecting more than 800.
it's like remarkable because
like i said i honestly didn't think we'd
get to this goal
when i put out the 147 about the other
night and then now we've way surpassed
it so it just makes me proud of
our community the sixtica first nation
is now working with ground penetrating
radar technicians
to conduct surveys on lands near these
residential schools
as well as on lands near two other
boarding schools that date back to the
1800s
they've asked for privacy through this
process but plan to make any findings
public
at a later date crane bear isn't sure
what will be found
but it's time he says this important
work is finally done
those you know uh lost children or
unmarked graves you know have to have
proper burial
and an acknowledgement recognition that
you know
they're found in a sense found honored
and remembered
a painful chapter of canada's past front
and center
on this canada day heather eurex west
global news
siksika first nation alberta
an investigation is also underway into a
fire at a catholic church on the saksica
first nation on monday
and overnight ten catholic churches in
calgary were vandalized
police are investigating orange and red
paint was smeared across the front
doors and walls of the churches police
say handprints and the number 215 and
other markings suggest
the attacks are in response to the
recent discovery of unmarked graves
at former residential school sites
it has been 154 years since
canada became a country and today is
normally filled with jubilant
celebrations
but this year many canadians including
the prime minister
are spending the day reckoning with
canada's treatment of
indigenous peoples and we as canadians
must be honest with ourselves about our
history
because in order to chart a new and
better path forward
we have to recognize the terrible
mistakes of our past
parliament hill would normally be packed
with people celebrating canada day
but as michael couture explains this
year the atmosphere
is very different
a sense of quiet reflection hung over
parliament hill on this canada day
morning
as people came to see the memorial to
victims of residential schools
the pandemic already pausing
celebrations here most other displays
were muted this year too
i needed to figure out something that
would help me heal
because i'm hurting
so this is the idea
he only wants to be identified as dave
and his message of inclusion
was just as simple he crafted canadian
flags with colored ribbons in memory of
indigenous children
and to honor the family killed in the
anti-muslim attack
in london ontario and he handed them out
to children today i resolved that you
know what today i got to do something
that's positive i got to do something
that's going to make me feel good
down the street a march to cancel canada
day made its way to parliament hill
demonstrators with a simple message for
anyone
resisting the reframing of this day oh
there's characters because they can't
party anymore
this is more important than canada today
it would seem that sentiment
is being felt mixed in with the
traditional red and white garb
was a lot of orange a recognition that
this day
doesn't bring joy for all we feel it
important to
you know to show up supporting canada's
actual history
and what happened but beyond that there
is a call for more action
not just in what people wear but more in
what they do
i want to see canada change its its
actions
change its mind change its tone
and that they will honor the first
peoples of this land
a past people need to recognize if we
have any chance at building a better
future
together mike licouter global news
ottawa
while many spent today reflecting others
celebrated
and not just because of canada day
people in alberta bc and newfoundland
and labrador are enjoying a much
anticipated easing
of coveted 19 restrictions today
alberta is open open for summer
in calgary it was a party-like
atmosphere with premier jason kenney
celebrating the start of alberta's third
and final stage of its reopening plan
nearly all restrictions have been lifted
the calgary stampede is able to go ahead
and there are no more limits on indoor
and outdoor gatherings in restaurants
stores
and places of worship bc2 has opened up
removing limits on dining masks are also
no longer mandatory
and newfoundland and labrador has
reopened to non-essential travelers from
outside atlantic canada
and if an international flight is on
your mind the european union is adding
canada to its safe travel list
opening the door to non-essential travel
to the region canada is just one of 10
countries that have been added to the
list
it's still up to member states to
determine if they would like to reopen
their borders to tourists
concerns have been raised about the eu's
new vaccine passport system
the kovi shield brand of the astrazeneca
vaccine which more than 270 000
canadians have received
is not approved for use in europe the
search in florida
briefly suspended coming up why crews
had to pause the recovery mission at a
collapsed condo
plus lawsuit dropped why the fan who
caused this crash
is no longer being sued
crews at the site if that deadly condo
building collapse
in florida resumed the rescue mission
late today
after the search was suspended over
fears about the stability of the
remaining structure
before that happened president joe biden
met with the families of the 142 people
still missing
about the agonizing and heartbreaking
delay
one week on from the sudden collapse
here's jackson proskow
minutes before the collapse witnesses
saw water pouring into the building's
underground garage
moments later they were surrounded by
complete devastation
one week on with dozens including four
canadians still missing
the dangerous rescue effort was stopped
for 18 hours
over fears the rest of the building
could collapse at any moment
and our engineers are continuing to
monitor
the structure as we've caused operations
to evaluate the situation and all
possible options and next steps
as families of the missing agonize over
what might be
firefighters revealed that in the hours
after the collapse they heard a woman
crying out from the rubble
and they were searching for a female
voice is what we heard for for several
hours and eventually we didn't hear our
voice anymore
the victims recovered and identified
include two children
ages 4 and 10 along with their parents
what you're doing here
is incredible president joe biden a man
intimately familiar with loss
met with relief workers visited a
growing public memorial
and sat privately with the families for
hours
they're praying and pleading that god
that to be a miracle let there be
something happen for me that's good
a federal investigation will involve
examining hundreds of tons of debris
now slowly being trucked away from the
collapse site to an undisclosed location
for analysis
as engineers work to stabilize the rest
of the building they face another
looming threat
a tropical storm has formed in the
atlantic and could track into south
florida
early next week pharah jackson proskow
in surfside florida thank you jackson
former u.s president donald trump's
company and its longtime
finance chief have been charged in what
prosecutors called a
sweeping and audacious tax fraud scheme
the indictment accuses the company of a
long-running conspiracy to help
executives including
chief financial officer alan weiselberg
evade
taxes on perks and bonuses while at the
same time decreasing the company's
own tax obligations donald trump says
his company's actions were
standard practice and in no way a crime
trump has not been charged at this stage
of the investigation
still ahead a new statue in honor of
princess diana
brings a royal rift back into the
spotlight
oh a huge crash that massive crash at
the tour de france on saturday is
apparently causing too much commotion
for the races organizers
they're withdrawing the lawsuit against
the spectator
who took down dozens of cyclists with
her cardboard sign
french police are still investigating
and the 30 year old french woman could
face up to two years in jail
race organizers say they're dropping the
complaint because the story
has been blown out of proportion
prince william and harry put differences
aside during the unveiling of a statue
in honor of their mother
on what would have been princess diana's
60th birthday
as crystal gomencing reports the statue
is a lasting tribute
to reflect diana's courage and
compassion
that defined the people's princess
their mother so often a unifying force
once again had the royal brothers within
arm's reach
as they honored the woman they and their
country love
so dearly for many
this is how they choose to remember
diana princess of wales
a doting mother a fashion icon and a
champion of the sick
and underprivileged a joint statement
was shared and posted on social media by
prince william and prince harry saying
every day we wish she were still with us
and our hope is that this statue will be
seen
forever as a symbol of her life and her
legacy
but the brothers relationship and their
highly publicized feud
could end up being all that's talked
about in the days ahead
i hope that we can keep the focus there
but there's no doubt that there will be
some talk about the drama some talk
about why megan's not there
why kate's not there you know if the
brothers stand next to each other don't
stand next to each other if they speak
if they don't speak
backs were turned while the princes
greeted guests and their mother siblings
but they also stood together chatted
smiled
and paid tribute to the woman they
dearly wish
was still in their lives the sculptor
said we wanted to capture her warmth and
humanity
while showcasing the impact she has had
across
generations everyone can now pay
tribute to the people's princess crystal
gomanson global news
london next the 11 year old boy nova
scotia who's walking for six days to
send
one powerful message
an eleven-year-old boy in nova scotia
began his long journey today
in memory of victims and survivors of
residential schools
landon tony will travel more than a
hundred kilometers
by foot landon is being accompanied by
his mom
and cousin and he's encouraging others
to join along
as ross lord reports he hopes his walk
will serve as an inspiration
at age 11 landon tony already has the
strength of his convictions
landon is walking for six days 157
kilometers
from his house in valley nova scotia to
the annapolis valley first nation
it's his way of honoring victims and
survivors of residential schools
it doesn't feel right like that there
was
kids my age that were dying from
older people like they got
whipped and stuff when they were bad and
they couldn't go home and if they tried
to they would either get killed or
punished landon is channeling his anger
into positive action i just want people
to feel better about themselves and
i just want people to know what's going
on
and that it wasn't too long ago too
like that could have been me in one of
those graves
his mother marsha mcclellan is helping
coordinate landon's journey of awareness
creating an online fundraiser and
joining the walk to make sure
her son stays safe he's proud to be who
he is
and he wants others to be proud of who
they are
and he wants people
to learn the truth
a painful truth for landon and his
migmaw ancestors
his great-grandmother was a survivor of
the residential school in nearby
shubenacity
where a search for remains that started
last year continues
his cousin keaton is also joining the
walk it shows people how
strong we are and how much we are gonna
we will
will stand up for our for our rights and
for our heritage
for this journey landon is stepping into
new territory
i do sports but i i never went for a
long walk in my life
but embarking on this challenge will be
worthwhile he says
if it helps others ross lord global news
landon you give us hope for the future
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm farin asser
thank you so much for spending part of
your canada day with us
we leave you tonight with orange
tributes from across the country
orange letters spell out every child
matters on a busy street in vancouver bc
to honor the survivors and victims of
residential schools
and the tower at the canadian museum of
human rights is shining orange in
winnipeg
wishing you peace this canada day
however you choose to commemorate
you